the wife of former mayor oscar goodman
and the second woman to hold that office
you can watch any of these mayors and
many others online at booktv.org simply
type mayor book into the search bar at
the top of the page
i think again
good evening i'm bradley graham the
co-owner of politics and pros along with
my wife lisa muscatine and on behalf of
the entire staff here at pnp welcome
thank you very much for coming
it really is
quite a treat to
have steve call with us to talk about
his new book directorate s
which is just out this week in fact this
is the
first time steve has had an opportunity
to do his kind of stand-up talk about
about the book
um steve of course is a is a legend in
in journalism for his prodigiousness
the clarity and an incisiveness of his
prose uh his ability to perceive the the
big picture
and his skill at presenting a grand
narrative of something
he spent 20 years at the washington post
including stints as a financial reporter
a foreign correspondent
ahead of the sunday magazine and for six
years
uh he was managing editor of the paper
after leaving the post a decade ago he's
served as a president of the new america
foundation then took over as dean of
columbia university's journalism school
he also continues to work as a
journalist on the staff of the new
yorker magazine
and along the way he's written revealing
books about
some very
big important subjects including
america's involvement in afghanistan the
bin laden family and exxon mobil
he's won two pulitzers one in 1990 for
explanatory journalism and another in
2004
for his book
ghost wars
that book recounted the cia's history in
afghanistan from the soviet invasion in
1979 to just before the 9 11 attacks
and his new work picks up
where ghost wars left off examining the
the past decade and a half
of ill-fated u.s efforts to achieve
victory in afghanistan
laid out chronologically in rich detail
featuring not just american players but
afghan pakistani and other key figures
the story that steve tells is a bleak
and appalling saga of missed
opportunities mistaken assumptions
misguided strategies and miscast
individuals
there's so much blame to go around
expanding democratic as well as
republican administrations and
implicating numerous intelligence
operatives military officers and
diplomats
but steve argues persuasively that what
has doomed the american war the most
has been the inability of u.s
authorities to understand the isi of
pakistan's intelligence service and stop
its covert interference in afghanistan
aimed at enlarging pakistan's sphere of
influence ladies and gentlemen please
join me in welcoming steve call
thank you brad thank you all for coming
out feel badly about people standing so
i won't
increase the volume
um
do i need to
lean into it a little bit is that better
everybody here all right okay good so
i'm sorry about the folks standing i
won't mind if you turn around and leave
at a certain point it's
it's warm in here
uh
c-span is with us so when we get to
questions i'm meant to ask you to come
up to the microphone
uh as brad mentioned i haven't given a
talk about this book so you're going to
get a a pilot a trial and i'm going to
learn a little bit about what works and
what doesn't i'm going to try to talk
for about 25 minutes to leave lots of
time for your questions
i'm glad you could come out
you know in the midst of
a stock market crash
the resignation of a white house
official for allegations of spousal
abuse and the imminent shutdown of the
federal government to talk about the
happy subject of afghanistan
so
as brad said uh
the title of the book director at s
refers to the covert action arm of the
inter-services intelligence
uh directorate the principal pakistani
intelligence service
although the united states has
has struggled with isis intentions and
activity
in afghanistan really from the beginning
of its uh
war there after the september 11th
attacks it's not as if isi was a mystery
to the united states because we
collaborated with isi the cia
collaborated with isi during the 1980s
to defeat the soviet occupation of
afghanistan
it was during the 1980s
with
american and saudi subsidies and with
the guns and the technology and the
power that came from
supporting the afghan mujahideen during
that war that isi grew into a state
within the state of
a corrosive force within pakistan that
began to influence politics as well as
regional policy
and uh you know it's commanded by the
army uh the top general in pakistan is
usually the most powerful person in the
country whether directly in power or
indirectly
and this service has you know maybe
about 25 000
people working in it some career
military officers some civilians
it spies on politicians and foreign
diplomats inside pakistan it collects
intelligence and capitals all over the
world usually about india sometimes
about pakistani dissidents military
threats
and it's divided into directorates like
the cia is there's one for analysis
there's one for eavesdropping and the
unit referred the unit that's in charge
of covert aid to islamist guerrillas
such as the taliban also other groups
fighting in kashmir
sometimes referred to by the americans
as director at s it's also known as
s-wing or just s inside pakistan
so
the war in afghanistan that's now in its
17th year it began in 2001 as a as a
hurried improvisation and counter-attack
to disrupt al qaeda
in the midst of
real uncertainty uh in the intelligence
community about what could be coming
next they'd missed 911 they feared
they're about to miss
another one
and
part of the intention of going in was to
disrupt al qaeda to get whoever might be
planning a second attack on the run or
thinking about something other than that
attack
there wasn't really much of a plan for
after the war it was barely a plan to
execute the war
and after the fall of the islamic
emirate
the taliban government in december of
2001
the question of why we were there and
what we intended to do
evolved into
a series of you know confused strategies
laced with contradictions sometimes
informed by illusions
that neither the bush administration nor
the obama administration
proved able to resolve
so one of the central questions in the
war all along for anyone who's been
involved in working on it
was
why the united states and nato was
willing to accept isi support for the
taliban even when
pakistan's covert action and passivity
about taliban sanctuaries in the country
directly undermined american interests
and cost american lives
there was a there's a character in the
book named chris woods who was a cia
officer who eventually ran the
counterterrorism
center he was a station chief in kabul a
couple times
and when he was there the last time i
think that he rotated in around 2011 you
know visiting congressmen and other
officials who came out would go in and
see him and talk about the war and
it was referred to as as his
uh hour of power
and uh
he told everybody you know we either
address the sanctuary the taliban enjoys
in pakistan and we win the war
or we don't and we lose the war it's
that simple
and it had seemed that simple to a lot
of analysts before him all the way back
to 2006 when the taliban started to
revive
and yet neither administration neither
the bush administration nor the obama
administration could find the will or
the way
to address this
so so why did we escalate the war after
2006
and and yet fail to achieve
our goals and why are we still there so
that's really the subject of the book
it's it's a
it's a narrative about
uh
how we got from
the eve of 9 11 to where we are today
uh it has a lot of episodes in it a lot
of characters it
one of my uh one of the sources i was
talking to sort of late in the project
in the fact-checking phase you know i
had kind of had a sense of
what the book scope was going to be
and he said you know we're probably not
going to have a pentagon papers about
this war for a long time i hope this is
the closest thing we have
and i thought well that's at least an
aspiration for the book and a way to
think about it
so i want to use my time to talk about
four things that i think contributed
to where we are today
apart from the kind of central problem
or
surrounding the central problem of
pakistan and its relationship with the
taliban and the taliban's ability to
access isi support and and geographical
sanctuary in pakistan
one is the problem of war aims our war
aims at different phases
second is our the failure of our
relationship with hamid karzai and our
investments in democratic afghan
politics more broadly
the third is
the illusions of our counter-insurgency
war in afghanistan
and the fourth is the failure of
american diplomatic and political
strategy in the war
at various points
so let's talk first about war aims
the bush administration and the obama
administration carried out more than
half a dozen secret interagency reviews
of why they were fighting in afghanistan
and how to achieve their aims a lot of
the sessions took place in the same
secure conference room on the fourth
floor of the eisenhower executive office
building next to the west wing
and the narrative keeps going back to
that room
scenes are remarkably similar all day
sessions interagency representation
often in the morning the intelligence
agencies would come in the analysts
would try to brief the facts here's a
map
this is what the taliban controls is
what the government controls here's the
demography of the war
here's our estimates about men under
arms
and then usually the professional
analyst would leave the room and the
policy makers would debate okay what do
we do now
and it was remarkable to go back and
excavate as best i could without access
to all of the notes and records but with
substantial access to what was discussed
and what was written what papers were
presented
that
the problem was so repetitious
and yet the solution was so
evasive
and here's
here's an example
um
in in all of the reviews that i was able
to
really unpack
of course it's a duty of policymakers
sending young american men and women to
war
to think through like what are the vital
interests that justify these sacrifices
and
in a number of the reviews they really
worked on that problem
and they settled on two for example in
2009 during the obama administration's
first review
they essentially found two interests
that could justify the sacrifices that
were being contemplated
one was al qaeda and its affiliates
because of the threat across borders
of additional terrorist attacks beyond
those that were already evident
and the second was this less
publicly pronounced usually because it
was so sensitive
but the security of pakistan's nuclear
weapons
country with a hundred nuclear weapons
dozens of terrorist groups
you don't want them to fall in the wrong
hands
okay so al qaeda
and pakistan nuclear weapons
but remember it's 2009.
neither of these problems is actually
located in afghanistan at that time
al qaeda had left afghanistan and gone
to pakistan what remnants survived the
u.s campaign in the fall of 2001
they had not only gone over to pakistan
they
lashed up with local groups and
inaugurated the worst years of domestic
terrorism that pakistan has ever known
destabilizing the country and of course
pakistan's weapons were not in
afghanistan
notwithstanding this mismatch
the
surge of troops a hundred thousand u.s
soldiers at the peak 150 000
international soldiers counting nato
contributions
was sent to afghanistan
because
of the rationale that if afghanistan
fell apart if the taliban triumphed al
qaeda would come back
which was a plausible concern but a
rather indirect way to define
war aims
and the second problem in this review
was one that recurs right to the present
day
all right al qaeda
we agree a menace
a threat
a relatively finite group
membership you know under 2000 at least
in the region
but the taliban are they an affiliate of
al qaeda are they as dangerous to the
united states as al qaeda
on what basis
they didn't participate in the 9 11
attacks it's not even clear from the
best scholarship that the leadership of
the taliban
knew about the 9 11 plot obviously they
were complicit they had created
sanctuary for al qaeda they were refused
repeated requests to do something about
al-qaeda
but after the fall of the taliban
government
what did the reviving taliban pose by
way of a threat direct threat across
borders to the united states or its
allies
this was a question
that all these reviews in that
conference room on the fourth floor of
the eisenhower building could never
settle
president obama
knew one thing he didn't want to fight
a forever war against the taliban
bob gates
the defense secretary at the time a
holdover from the bush administration
he pointed out you know the taliban are
part of afghanistan
we're not in a position to fight a long
war against them
the pentagon
wanted to fight a war
against them but
it wasn't able to persuade many of the
civilian decision makers including those
like the secretary of defense that it
had a plan that made sense in terms of
the cost and the outcomes that were
likely to be achieved
at one point during these reviews in
this building
they got into an argument about
well have we ever said that we wanted to
defeat the taliban
i'm not sure that we have
and
the next day the pentagon came back with
a big powerpoint deck putting up all the
statements that different officials had
said over the years saying we're going
to defeat the taliban they said um okay
well
i guess we have to say something
eventually they came out of that review
with a plan to
degrade the taliban and reverse its
momentum you know language that is so
strikingly vague
as a war aim
that it just kind of begs examination
um
i mentioned that
these reviews returned to the vital
interest of the security of pakistan's
nuclear weapons
i think that was also a fairly easy
consensus to reach but what did it imply
it meant that the stability of pakistan
and the military's control over the
country's nuclear facilities was crucial
so the more violent the american-led war
in afghanistan became the more it
clearly destabilized pakistan spilling
violence over the border pushing al
qaeda into pakistan
and touching off as i mentioned after
2007 the worst years of internal
terrorism the country had ever known
so you have dozens of militant groups
more than 100 nuclear weapons and a
worsening war
now you recognize that directorate s is
part of your problem in afghanistan but
what can you do to pressure it when
you're so constrained you're all you've
already destabilized pakistan
and if you if you go in heavy with
pressure
you're only going to make this situation
worse
during the last
review of the bush administration late
2008
president bush approved the
the kind of analysis
uh that was more or less along the lines
that i've just described at a national
security council meeting
but he he pointed out he said you know
we're suggesting the obama
administration that they increase
resources to the war in afghanistan
but everything you're telling me is that
the problem is in pakistan isn't there
more that we can do
and the cia has says well we can we can
do drone attracts
drone attacks across the border
they'll make some difference
but the real problem is in quetta the
real problem is in karachi the real
problem is in the heart of pakistan
the president says well can we go there
and michael hayden was then the director
of the cia and he says sir blowing
buildings up in the middle of one of
pakistan's major cities is a lot
different than an isolated mud hut
getting struck out in the mountains
somewhere
they were constrained
president obama could not figure out how
to resource the war against the taliban
enough to win it
or on the other hand
how to define his war aim so narrowly to
focus only on al qaeda
that the taliban problem could be evaded
they went forward with this plan to
reverse the momentum and degrade the
taliban
because they knew that
pursuing a military defeat of the
taliban was implausible
hamid karzai
so it's become fashionable i think to
think about
karzai as someone who turned out to be
unstable consumed by conspiracy theories
there's no question and his behavior in
private was often unbalanced the book
describes this again and again
there was a scene though where karzai
goes walking in the garden with one of
his ministers
and the minister says to him you know mr
president i do think the americans have
been unfair to you
initially
you were an afghan mandela
now all of a sudden you're an afghan
mugabe
that's not right
one of the threads in the narrative is
how this relationship unraveled
from the mandela years
forward
and one of the things that even as
someone who was going there a lot as a
magazine reporter felt kind of like a
beat reporter on the war and interviewed
karzai a couple of times
one of the things that really struck me
when i went back and tried to unpack
this you know meeting by meeting year by
year documenting as much of what was
said in private as i possibly could
is that you know every time karzai
received an american visitor almost from
2004 until the last day that he was in
office
the first and last and most emphatic
thing he said was
you got to do more about isi you got to
do more about pakistan the war is over
the border
and over time he could not understand
why the united states was unable
to address this problem
he took it for granted that the u.s as
the world supreme military power could
force isi
to stop aiding the taliban if it really
wanted to do so and since the u.s did
not take this action as the years went
by
his thinking sunk into conspiracies
he figured there had to be another
explanation
eventually he concluded that the u.s was
secretly
hoping that isi would destabilize
afghanistan so it could justify keeping
long-term military bases in the country
there's a diplomat in 2013 james dobbins
who's a special envoy he goes to visit
karzai karzai rolls this theory out on
him again it's not the first time that
americans heard it by now
and dobin says something the effect of
you know mr president by now you've got
the snowden documents you've got the
wikileaks materials
literally millions of pages can you see
in these documents any trace of this
plan
and karzai says maybe you don't know the
plan
is that there's a deep state in america
another episode that
is very dispiriting to recount in kind
of the fullness of
that
this kind of retrospective reporting
allows
was the 2009 election debacle remember
this was when jamie karzai was
re-elected
richard holbrook came in and was
meant to be the special envoy to
afghanistan and pakistan he was
immediately estranged from the white
house obama didn't appreciate his style
but he thought that
the diplomacy around the election was
his lane in washington lingo and he was
going to try to shape this election
he used to say that diplomacy was like
jazz it's a little bit of improvisation
that's required and he started to move
toward the election date
by basically talking to as many
potential alternatives to karzai
as he could identify
here's a scene where he runs into a
brother of the laid ahmed shah massoud
says you know i think i'm the only
person in kabul who you have not invited
to run against karzai i i should feel
insulted
and karzai of course got wind of this
almost immediately
and
he became understandably upset and
paranoid that the americans were out to
overthrow him
but holbrook had no authorization from
the white house to replace karzai
and he had no plan to actually achieve
the goal
and to make uh episodic and quite uh
vivid stories short
we end up with the worst of both worlds
in this case
karzai is re-elected
and he believes with reason that the
united states is out to get him uh and
he's infuriated about that and it shapes
along with his befuddlement about our
inability to coerce pakistan into
changing its conduct
his his growing estrangement from the
u.s
i mentioned this walk
with the minister the same one where
they talked about mugabe and mandela
um
karzai says to his colleague
you know if we can't run the government
this is after the election debacle after
all these pleadings that the u.s has not
responded to he says you know if we
can't run the government we should bring
the taliban back
to punish both the americans and the
panchiris he says referring to the
northern alliance
his son karzai's young son mir weiss
happens to be with them
and the minister asks do you want this
boy to grow up under a taliban regime
i don't want that for my son
if the government collapses he said
the u.s will not be threatened but we
will be wiped out
and that is what kept karzai
on side barely the knowledge that they
were a dependency and it infuriated him
more and more as time went on
that he had become
on the one hand the americans who
visited him would tell him you are the
sovereign president of afghanistan we
respect you and we will uh deal with you
as a sovereign and on the other hand
every time he objected to american
counterinsurgency doctrine or
its policies military campaigns or
the way that they had gotten involved in
the in the election
um he was ignored and he understood that
he was powerless
despite this loose talk which was
repeatedly offered to his aides and
sometimes to the americans
of changing sides cutting a deal with
isi
bringing the taliban back
he couldn't act
because
he wasn't in a position to do so
all right i've got just
maybe five or six minutes left and two
two other things i wanted to touch on
um
one was the counterinsurgency campaign
that began
in 2008 2009 in earnest
when obama took office and after a
series of very tangled reviews
partially endorsed the recommendations
of his commanding general stanley
mcchrystal to carry out a
counter-insurgency campaign
decided at the same time in december of
not 2009 to announce that he was
ordering an additional surge of troops
into afghanistan but he also announced
the date when they would withdraw so
we're going in and we're going out
kind of a
paradoxical announcement so typical of
these strategy reviews and and the
policy throughout
but as a counter-insurgency campaign the
afghanist the afghan
war in 2009 it created a real math
problem so in counter-insurgency
doctrine the typical
idea is that you need a ratio of 20
soldiers and police for every thousand
local inhabitants
in afghanistan that would have required
as many as 600 000 security forces which
was an unrealistic number
even involving the rapid buildup of
afghan security forces
so they narrowed the problem by
confining the counter-insurgency war to
80 key terrain districts
these were districts in taliban
countries selected
from the south and along the border with
pakistan
and this whole formulation soon became a
kind of over over determined engineering
diagram
it birthed a jargon-filled language of
acronyms and district stability
frameworks
pentagon briefers would exclaim slogans
such as
it's great to make sure the population
is attached to the government
and the mantra of clear whole build
transfer meaning transfer territory rid
of taliban influence to a legitimate
afghan government and security forces
was
an illusion
the entire sequence of hold bill
transfer was based on wishful thinking
the british envoy working with
uh holbrook advised very early on the
way the white house warsaw doug lut put
it was to obama around this time was he
said you know mr president
you can send a battalion of u.s marines
not only anywhere in afghanistan but
literary literally anywhere in the world
and they'll clear an area
and as long as you're willing to keep
them there they'll hold it
the problem is handing the cleared area
to the afghans and doing something with
it
finally i just want to mention the
problem of politics and diplomacy
here's another contradiction that just
keeps recurring in the narrative when
you kind of unpack the phases of our
experience there
so one after another america's top
generals you know they arrive to command
the war in afghanistan
and they'll say in public explaining
their plan to the afghans and to the
american people
that peace cannot be achieved in this
war by military means alone
and yet year after year military
strategy is by far the greatest priority
i think it was david petraeus during his
tour in 2011 who said you know you can't
capture and kill your way out of an
industrial strength insurgency
these wars end through negotiations
and the war cabinet in the obama years
you know repeatedly affirmed that there
would have to be a political solution
that accommodated at least some elements
of the taliban and afghan politics
but if the afghan war could be settled
only by negotiations that incorporated
at least as many defectors from the
taliban as possible
why was this line of political and
diplomatic
action not prioritized year after year
this was a stove-piped war the pentagon
ran its war the cia ran its war
richard holbrooke who was estranged from
the white house was told to run his
diplomacy it was not a whole of
government political or diplomatic
strategy by any stretch
and when i went back through all of this
i was present when a lot of this was
going on and you know building my
diaries and interviewing people in real
time but
when i went back and unpacked this
particular failure i found it
particularly frustrating because when
you think about the obama
administration's
achievements in diplomacy
working with holding russia and china
and europe on side to negotiate
a 10-year standstill agreement with iran
over its nuclear program i mean talk
about a hard problem
they got it all the way to the finish
line
they decided to reverse decades
of policy toward cuba despite the
treacherous politics in the united
states
they worked on it sometimes in secret
sometimes in semi-secret and they got it
done
and yet here where we had all these
soldiers on the battlefield
two thousand plus dead twenty thousand
wounded so many lot limbs lost
and we didn't bring
our best game to this
politics this negotiation this
no matter how treacherous no matter how
difficult
it was a war that was running almost on
automatic pilot in a lot of ways the
book tells the story of the conflict
resolution cell that was set up in 2010
with the president's strong endorsement
in the white house to try to secretly
negotiate with the taliban
to try to bring the war to an end
and it was a significant effort and it's
a fascinating story who they were
negotiating with on the other side
you know these moments when
tayabhaga the taliban negotiator comes
and
brings a letter from
supposedly from omar on taliban
stationary for president obama
the letter says you know mr president
i've had to make some difficult
decisions with my people to let these
talks go forward now you should step up
and show a little courage let's let's
let's negotiate
the talks failed for a number of reasons
one of which was hamid karzai
was not
connected enough to the u.s
to participate as a constructive partner
in them
another was isi which wanted to control
the talks
that the taliban didn't want the isi as
a negotiating agent
not to not to suggest this was going to
be an easy process but it didn't
when you when you read how it unfolded
it did not represent the best
capacities or traditions of american
diplomacy
and the stakes yet were so high
so i'm anxious for your questions
so i think i will just wind down
one thing that hasn't changed in the war
is isis role
there's a in in
august of 2016
so just as we were getting ready to turn
the war over to the third administration
to fight it
there was a
unmarked white helicopter that went down
in logar
province
it's an area that steve levine will
remember i think we've both been there
it was like the
main isi supply route into char siobh
and up into kabul because it was
shielded by all these high ridge
mountains you could basically drive a
truck from pakistan
to about uh i don't know
40 clicks from kabul without ever kind
of breaking cover and that's where the
helicopters would also fly so this
helicopter crashed
and
had a russian pilot
and some people from pakistan on board
and a bunch of supplies
taliban surrounded it
hustled the pilots and all of the
passengers back to pakistan burned the
helicopter and disappeared with the
supplies
the afghan said
this looks like an isi operation
pakistan said no
the helicopter was flying to central
asia for repairs
so the trump administration has come in
and they've certainly taken a tougher
line on pakistan they've suspended aid
they've tweeted uh aggressively
um
we have you know 10 to 15 000 troops on
the ground
one-tenth the number that we had
when
at the peak of the obama surge
the
the book describes this exercise the
cia's war analytical unit would do every
six months called the district
assessments
these color-coded maps of afghanistan's
400 and plus administrative districts
one color indicating government control
and other color indicating
taliban control another color indicating
contested or local control
and
they were the maps were a big hit
because they were really fun to look at
they kept unfurling them on these tables
in the eisenhower office building they'd
update them every six months and
throughout all this history from the
beginning of the ser from the end of the
bush administration through the 150 000
troop peak
to the withdrawal of u.s uh forces and
the prioritization of afghan
security forces in the lead of combat
to today
the essential picture on those maps has
not changed the war is a stalemate it's
a stalemate because
the
taliban can't achieve their objectives
they don't have an air force and they
don't have any way to defeat the us air
force and anytime they mass
they make themselves instantly
vulnerable to american air power that's
why they haven't been able to take
significant cities even though they've
sometimes had momentum
and the us and its afghan partners have
not been able
to substantially change taliban control
of the countryside in the areas where
it's particularly strong there's
things move around on the map but the
essential picture of the war has stayed
the same
so we're in our 17th year
and when the next president is sworn in
or this president is sworn in again
in january 21
my my senses will still be still being
this war
so thank you for listening
[Applause]
so if you could give advice to the next
president
um since giving advice to this one
doesn't seem to
do anything except upset him
um what would you suggest
i mean this isn't the first time this
sounds like vietnam all over again in
some ways
look i mean i'm i'm it's hard enough
just to try to tell you what happened
uh
i i really am and you know sort of
um
not uh
uh i'm kind of reluctant to give people
advice about this history but i i think
the
the common sense a couple of common
sense answers um
you know
you know if you look at a lot of history
of war especially long stalemated wars
like this one
um a natural response would be you know
not to keep doing the same things over
and over again and expect different
results right
and you know i think the trump
administration for example has persuaded
itself that what it's doing differently
is withholding aid from pakistan
showing resolve we're going to stay
until the last terrorist loosening the
rules of combat even though there are
many fewer forces that were there when
the war still mated in 2011
um and
and that somehow this
kind of resurgence of of will willpower
on the battlefield will lead to some
kind of
um capitulation by the taliban or
pakistan
and you know that's
i just don't see what the evidence is uh
for that hypothesis um and
uh
you know it it's a feel-good posture
that you can that you can take um
for him well and you know look i mean
i like everyone who's been to
afghanistan who's worked in afghanistan
i have nothing but um
empathy for the afghan
people for this constitutional
government for the for the afghans who
came home in 2002 to kind of restore
their country that had been destroyed by
the soviet invasion and the wars that
followed you know afghanistan
was at peace with itself and its
neighbors for most of the 20th century
the the restoration that took place in
2002 was not imposed on it by the
international community it was an afghan
effort to recover their country they
still have a constitutional government
it is factionalized it is cracking up it
is still there though they control the
cities there's a young population that's
come of age in those cities
that's connected to the world it's a
different afghanistan than any before it
and i wouldn't want to see that collapse
so you know i'm not suggesting that we
pack up and go home
but
to
try to get from here to a better place
to reduce the violence
to if even if you even if a political
settlement is
a quixotic goal
the purpose of negotiations and
diplomacies and diplomacy in environment
like this is to reduce the violence to
give space to give breathing space and
the only way that's going to happen is
if the powers that shape events in
afghanistan
besides the united states
china
russia
pakistan
iran
you can go on india
are part of an effort
to achieve the what is in fact the
common interest of a more stable less
violent
less toxic less terrorist infested
afghanistan
that's hard work that requires
high-level diplomacy the kind of
diplomacy that the obama administration
carried out
in the iran deal that the bush
administration first bush administration
carried out
in the context of the first gulf war
you know
it's an all-in all day kind of project
using all of the levers that the united
states has and
with allies
so
the remarkable thing is we haven't
really made that effort around this war
since the bond agreement we did then
and so i guess
i would start there because it can't be
worse than where we are now
sounds good
hi steve hi dan um
rather than look forward let's look
backwards then uh you spoke at the very
beginning about missed opportunities
and uh especially with isid
uh i'm wondering what are the tools that
you think the united states had that
could have leveraged isid to do
something differently than than what it
did i reflect back on the failure of our
withholding f-16s as you recall and how
they gathered dust out in arizona i mean
that wasn't a very effective lever in
the end so i'm wondering what are the
levers you would identify
yeah i mean i
they're different at different times of
the story i mean counterfactual history
i think is
not a it's kind of a fool's game but you
can't help but think about the question
where were the most significant missed
opportunities
in my mind they were in the period 2004
to 2000 i mean 2002 to 2004 after the
islamic emirate fell
after the taliban leadership melted into
pakistan afghanistan was relatively
peaceful
many afghans came home to rebuild
the international community was united
in support of the constitutional
government created at bonn
and
what happened
we turned immediately to iraq
there's a scene in the book where the
generals who are
sent to afghanistan summer in 2002 to
stand up a task force yeah it's lightly
resourced rumsfeld is
determined not to
permit large-scale military or
reconstruction aid in afghanistan
because of his belief that we're not um
nation builders but these generals go
off get called to a conference in
brussels while they're just trying to
get organized for what peacekeeping they
can consolidate in afghanistan and they
come back and they say to their
colleagues we're going to war in iraq
this is you know may june 2002
and of course the incentive structure
inside the
military inside the intelligence
services immediately shifts this is
where we're going now
so that's one thing that happened the
other thing that happened is that we had
no plan
to
account for the defeated taliban
in the politics of the bond agreement
okay
after war what is the wisdom of victory
it is to try to
reconcile with as many of the defeated
enemy as possible as we did in germany
as we did in japan
yes you can hold leadership accountable
you can identify war crime war criminals
and hold them accountable but the foot
soldiers
the the lieutenants
there has to be a plan
we made this mistake twice once in
afghanistan and again with the bath
party in iraq
and the consequences in afghanistan were
that our policy was despite
some arguments that i that i am able to
document in the book from to the other
side offering an alternative to this
was that any taliban foot soldier was a
candidate for guantanamo
and we would call people to meetings you
know say let's talk about politics and
then we'd arrest them and put them in
jumpsuits and send them away
and then the third thing
after a couple of years of this
combination of neglect and harshness
you know i think there's a study that i
described in the in the book from the
spring of 2006 when amarillo saleh who
led the afghan intelligence service at
that time
he sees the taliban coming back and he
decides to do a kind of a field study of
what's going on and what are their
motivations where are they going
describes how he goes out into the
provinces and he pays taliban commanders
to come in and talk to him and submit to
interviews and you know in afghanistan
there's really no no impermeable lines
people people will cross and talk to
each other
and
and he concludes that you know isi is
is supporting this resurgence for a
couple of reasons one is that
afghanistan has by now consolidated its
constitutional government it had a
successful presidential election in 2004
it has parliamentary elections it has
the international community support and
it's looking like a long-term ally of
india with international backing
and remember the other signal we sent to
pakistan during this time
we signed this big civilian nuclear deal
with india
in which we essentially forgave india
for
breaking out of the non-prolifera
proliferation treaty promised them
long-term strategic partnership and then
we turned around and said to pakistan
you don't get this deal you're never
going to get this deal you're the
country of aq con you're not reliable
enough to have it
it's clearly evidence that in the
pakistani high command around that time
musharraf and his core commanders start
talking to themselves saying
you know first of all afghanistan is
becoming an ally of our enemy second of
all the americans don't believe in us as
strategic partners they are making a
long-term commitment to india and third
because of the iraq war
and and our
decision not to invest heavily in afghan
reconstruction and security after 2002
we turned the afghan security operation
over to nato allies
in order to free up our forces to fight
in iraq
so the pakistanis look across the border
and they see the canadians coming into
kandahar they see the brits coming to
helm on they see the dutch coming to ur
is gone and they say this is not serious
we're we're already in a post-american
afghanistan
we got to get going and so that was i
think where the isi
kind of revival of the taliban was
located in some of in some combination
of those factors
so you've not identified any specific
levers that would have uh impacted the
strategic level i think i think
strategic i think you would have had to
incorporate pakistan into
a post-war politics a post you would
have had to incorporate them into
a wiser approach to the post-war
settlement now you know there are
coercive policies that you could try to
bring against isi officers and specific
individuals travel sanctions those
things we may see the trump
administration try some of this it was
argued about at various points in both
the bush and obama administration
especially obama administration
but the record of sanctions in the 1990s
and the depth of pakistan's relationship
with china
you know to me argues that
that kind of coercion by itself if it's
not coupled with some kind of
negotiation
involving pakistan's patrons or other
regional powers
it's not going to succeed thank you
thank you good evening steve thank you
evening steve thank you for coming um i
want to shift gears for just a second
with a quick question can you be induced
to do a combo ghost wars director of s
on iraq from july 1991 through 18 march
2003
no no
before we take this question i'm just
going to say uh we have time for
everybody who's in line now but we won't
have time for any more questions okay
thank you
i
question i have is
you you touched on it i guess
12 years as to what it wanted 12 years
ago is what does
isi want
is there a way that we can accommodate
it now
because it sounds like
in a way this is a redux of
what the us was facing in vietnam where
the vietcong and north vietnamese used
cambodia
and what nixon did then was bomb the
hill out of regions of cambodia and laos
i don't think that's something the u.s
will do
it sounds to me like pakistan is trying
to have it both ways on the war it's
charging the u.s for ferrying supplies
into
afghanistan and
it's also benefiting by
i guess they're probably getting
something from the taliban having them
in the country and being free to go into
afghanistan i'm wondering
what they're the closest what to
afghanistan essentially except for iran
what
what can be done to try to accommodate
them well this is a big part of the
story in the in the book especially
during the obama administration there's
um
you know they there's
in very close conversation with the head
of the pakistan army who's a kind of
character in the book ashwa khayani
you know again and again the americans
are saying to him well what do you
really want what's good enough
because after all it's not about just
the united states and pakistan afghans
have to buy into whatever political
settlement is stretched after the bond
agreement is made afghans are talking to
afghans about what kind of settlement
might work internally but
pakistan's involvement as a spoiler
makes it very difficult to have any kind
of clean negotiation
and you know what the answer is that
in these conversations
at one point kind who writes a secret
paper he hands it to obama and says this
is what i want the americans look at it
it essentially says
i want an adequate amount of political
influence in afghanistan and space for
pashtuns whether they're taliban or
non-taliban to participate fully in
afghan politics we feel that we don't
have that yet now the afghans would say
the hell you don't but
at least it was a sort of sense that
they backed off of their claim of saying
we don't want total control we don't
want the taliban back in power we just
want a better political settlement so
that was one thing but also on the list
we're a bunch of other things
we want
access to we want a free trade deal with
the united states we want the civilian
nuclear deal you gave india we want your
support on our goals in kashmir we want
your investment in our water disputes
with india we want um
our energy deficits addressed we want
you to you know holistically embrace us
the way a true ally would if we were you
know in trouble in germany or the uk you
would come in with the imf and you would
fix all this
and you know the americans looked at
this paper and they said you know wow
okay honest talk
but this is impossible
and and you know before they could even
really digest it
you hit 2011 raymond davis
osama bin laden
and and the whole relationship collapses
so you know it's not as if these
questions haven't been grappled with at
a sophisticated level but they were
never um
you know sort of dealt with
in a whole uh they were always kind of
fraught and and isolated discussions
even at the highest levels
congratulations on the book i want to
ask you a question about craft
you acknowledge that you are writing
about a war that is still ongoing and
you referenced an anecdote between
ambassador dobbins and president karzai
how do you go about researching and
writing a book like this and which
documents are you waiting for for their
declassification date in the future
um
well
i mean my my i only know how to do these
things one way and that's why they i
always produce these very very long
books i've got to figure out how to
write hundred thousand word books
instead of 220 000 word books but i just
can't figure it out
but you know i know my my reporting
methodology is a combination of um
in
first and foremost interviewing
second documents that i can obtain from
original sources that provide ballast
for chronology specificity
contemporaneous authenticity of what was
said what was done
third
other documents that i can obtain
through declassification or through
resources like wikileaks or other you
know subjects um state department cables
were in fact pretty helpful uh for the
chronology because they're very granular
about dates and and kind of themes and
they when i was interviewing or when i
had access to my own original um
written uh
sources from my own original sources i
could always
kind of backstop those against that
record it was helpful in that way um
and then the fourth layer is just all of
the scholarship all of the books all of
the analysis that's out there try to
absorb it all it doesn't usually turn up
in the pages except and kind of
regurgitate it through my own kind of
thinking and and framing of things but
i i read you know i try to absorb
everything um and
and it's um
yeah it's a it's
this book was um
you know maybe 10 years in the making
and what would be the thing that you're
waiting for
well i mean there's a there's a lot of
episodes where i was able to surround
something through interviewing some you
know contemporary documents of various
kinds
but where there were disputes about what
really happened that i couldn't resolve
let me give you a simple one that i
think you know may come out
with more documentation earlier than
others
you know this whole episode of tora bora
when bin laden escaped
okay i mean the senate foreign relations
committee did a pretty good
investigation was almost entirely based
on interviews that's probably the most
thorough account that you have of
of kind of why we didn't go up and block
bin laden from escaping into pakistan
and you know could we have finished the
war against al qaeda's leadership that
early would it have made a difference i
don't know but why didn't we finish it
that was why we were there and we didn't
lift those troops up there and there's
kind of an oral history of
you know woulda coulda i said we should
have done it you know
different people saying i argued we
should have gone
other people saying no you didn't
actually
and i i really felt like i tried to give
you the best
uh account of what happened and what the
factors were that i could based on
on my research
but i felt like you know this is
something that could be settled if you
would just give me the documents
and there's a bunch of things that are
very specific i think it kind of you
know important to our understanding of
the history of the war
i'd like to go back to one of your
earlier books the one on exxonmobil
private empire
you
wrote about tillerson when he was
in his own world
and the most successful person in that
world
what do you think
is happening with him
has happened to him
and where he goes from here
uh you know i'm not i'm not a state
state department reporter um anymore
but
i um
you know i
when he came in i thought that he would
do better than than he has done
i i could see where his uh
problems were going to arise at least a
few of them and they have
borne out one is you know when you're
the ceo of exxon mobil you live
you live in a bubble
you're you know you're always flying
private planes everyone around you is
supporting your leadership everyone is
telling you what you
want to hear no one challenges
your opinion you're the boss
we all know the secretaries of state are
not the boss they have to compete with
the white house for influence over
foreign policy and with this white house
you know even if it had been
you know james baker would have been a
pretty challenging job but one of the
ways that
secretaries of state
gain influence
in administration in my experience is by
using the bully pulpit that the
secretary has distinctively after the
president to speak for the united states
to just stand up and say this is what i
think
you have so many opportunities yeah you
can clear your speeches but you're also
in front of the microphone a lot and
it's not unusual to have a secretary of
state who's
fighting with the white house or
isolated from the white house i mean
think of you know clinton and obama
after all the blood bad of that campaign
but the way you overcome that from foggy
bottom is you you stand up and speak you
make yourself felt you kind of create
facts through your own activity well
you know tillerson was never a public
communicator he never played that role
he never answered questions from the
press
that weren't super controlled he never
thought about
communication as three-dimensional chess
where you're speaking you know with
allies you're not just speaking to your
counterpart which is what an oil company
does right you negotiate with the leader
of a country or the leader of another
oil company one on one and that's all it
is but in diplomacy
we live in a world of allies that are
also democracies you're speaking not
just to their governments but to their
parliaments to their publics
you know to your adversaries
this is this is
a lifetime's work and then the last
thing i would say is he came into
government unlike other executives
who've come from the private sector into
government without any prior experience
of government
you know george schultz ran bechtel but
he had been in and out of government
uh a number of times before he became
secretary and
you know at exxon mobil they tended to
regard the government as as a hostile
entity uh the u.s government they were
very explicit that they thought the
state department wasn't very good it was
full of anti-oil career diplomats
that they didn't negotiate very
effectively
and so to come in and take over um a
diplomatic service that you don't
have experience with and that you don't
necessarily respect is a you know
prescription for for what we've seen
thank you
uh good evening
so when you were doing research and
conducting interviews for this book what
did your access to isi officials look
like if there was any did you find them
forthcoming or do you think there was
any attempt to mislead you
mislead me
um
you know i i would refer you to the
footnotes um
because i don't really want to get into
a qualitative discussion about my
sourcing but one of my goals was
to
i try to provide as much transparency as
i can consistent with my commitments to
my sources uh in the footnotes
but one of my broader goals which was
you know it's true in in ghost wars too
and i but i really i'm not saying i got
all the way there but it was really
something i thought about every month
that i was working on this project i
wanted to provide
equal empathy to the perspectives of
decision makers and characters in all
three of the countries that i was
writing about so i didn't want the
pakistani characters to be any less full
any less listened to any less understood
than the americans inevitably
you know
with systems i understood the american
system better
but i've spent a lot of time in pakistan
and i understand you know something of
the way things really work but but i
what i could really do was to is to make
sure i understood the people
and their institutional kind of setting
and the way they saw the world
and why they took the decisions they
took and i tried to do the same you know
in afghanistan as well
i think the place where i struggled the
most was with
uh the taliban you know i think a great
book about this war would bring
the queen ashura to you know sort of
intimate life the way you know i could
get the pakistani army's high command
humanized and brought up in a big vivid
way i thought
but
uh
omar was not available for an interview
thank you
one more question uh thank you this is
ahmad from pakistan i am a scholar in
national defense university
from a common pakistani perspective
there is a lot of debate about
american very little recognization of
pakistan sacrifices in war on terror so
your comments on this and uh two little
question one is did pakistan and its
leadership
was really on board during the obl
operation
and this question will might strike you
that did pakistan ever stood against u.s
national interest
in this whole history of unstable
relationship uh in this and in
particularly in this war under thank
yous
um yeah i mean on the last question you
know yes uh because pakistan
accommodated and and supported groups
that were crossing the border from
pakistan to afghanistan to attack and
kill american soldiers and to
destabilize the war that the united
states was trying to stabilize so
that was the central problem from the
american perspective
you know the the
second question um or the first one
about the pakistani sacrifices in the
war i think is an important one and it
was what i tried to allude to you know
in my earlier
talk about how
the war destabilized pakistan and what a
price pakistan paid for that you know it
wasn't the intention of the united
states to flush al qaeda out and have
them go into pakistan and start car
bombing pakistani cities and to go to
war against the pakistani state but it
was the result of the american invasion
and from a pakistani perspective when
the americans would come in in 2010 2011
and bang on the table do more about the
haqqanis do more about the taliban
leadership and the pakistanis would look
around and say do you not see the smoke
on the horizon i mean i am at war with
my own
militants and
one of the things that kayani was always
saying to the americans during this
period was i cannot afford to take
actions that tip my war against my own
domestic taliban from 98 percent against
2 percent to 50 50 because then the
state is going to collapse i am trying
to control this war so that we can win
it and we can keep public opinion on our
side
and it was a serious crisis i mean you
may not remember in 2009 spring of 2009
when the pakistani taliban came pouring
out a swat and started running on
towards islamabad i mean there was a
genuine sense in washington
the state might collapse
you know they fought back
gradually they regained control but
really was only in 2015 if you look at
the numbers that the pakistani forces
were able to get
terrorism back to a level that it had
been domestically
you know in say 2004 2005 and even then
500 civilians died in 2015 2016.
so you know
that's part of the
360 degrees perspective that i think you
know you need to bring to this if you're
trying to to
figure out what it means and where to go
from here thank you so much for being
here i appreciate it
[Applause]
thank you steve copies of steve's book
are available at the checkout desk he'll
be up here signing please form a line to
the right of the table got some water
right
is
here